[Music]
carlene is the national game of ireland
and that predates irish history in
ancient times helped young warriors the
perfect battle you have to be physical
you have to be brave because we want to
take the hips as a spectator it's just
something that can take your breath away
this great big story is inspired by
Genesis going up my grandfather always
told me that to most Irish things you do
was to speak the language not to play
hardly my Irish isn't fluent but I have
a harder I developed my skills in this
very garage here you've been here 1 2
hours a day just striking the ball off
the wall I'm from Donegal it's cut in
North West of Ireland Donegal will be a
very rural area part one we is popular
here as it will be downsized but people
dedicate their lives to it
[Music]
there are 32 countries in Ireland within
each of those countries there is club
teams which make up the kind of team I
pay him for my clubs Atlanta since I was
7 years of age it's a cover my
grandfather founded back in 1979 -
called my father were played for and
then when I was 16 I started playing
senior level for Donegal over the last
many years I've been capped left only
goal which has been a privilege for me
because you're representing both your
club and your kind date and your
teammates
[Music]
hardness fastest feeding sport on grass
this means the ball can move from one
end of the pitch in the space of two or
three seconds if you watch to give a
hard line you think there is no Roos
involved here but for a harder arrest
there's a lot of method behind the
madness
there's 15 players on each team two
teams on a field with two goals inner
ends the me and skills involved are
picking up the ball striking of the ball
and your compete against other team to
score opposite ends of food it's summer
to the cross because you're passionate
ball with a stick what's on like a cross
where you have a net using a flat piece
of ash and just mix that much more
difficult because you're not guaranteed
control the ball there is some big heads
that wouldn't be out of place and Marion
football game but you got to really be
brave get back up in your feet and go
again
[Music]
like the 19th century when items on
their british-ruled arrays of hurling
came in concert with the Rays of the
independence movement in many parts of
Ireland especially the North playing the
game of hurling is not just about
playing sports but keeping your hyeri's
identity keeping your Irish history
alive it becomes more important than
your job the more important than
anything else by your family and pull
that's okay hold the ball once a young
lad picks up a stick he strikes a ball
over time he developed a connection to
the game because it's raw full of
passion
it's just represents everyone items of
words
you